[Musique]
il s'appelait sa mère pattie son nom
résonne aujourd'hui dans notre hémicycle
comme celui d'un martyr de la république
mort pour avoir enseigné la liberté
d'expression n'oublions jamais
n'oublions jamais pour ses proches pour
nos enseignants et pour la france
ne pas oublier ce n'est pas seulement
laisser couler les armes les larmes de
la république sous forme d'hommage de
rassemblement ne pas oublier c'est
surtout monsieur le premier ce ne pas
oublier d'agir assez de renoncement à
ces de résignation et de capitulation
coupable la république du pas de vagues
c'est la république qui abdique et qui
au final laisse passer les islamistes
ils sont passés et depuis trois ans
votre majorité a refusé
ch'ti thématiquement toutes nos
propositions contre l'islamisme radical
ce que nous vous demandons c'est le
courage de réarmer la république mais
nous vous demandons aussi de faire aimer
la france
ne cédez pas ne cédez pas vraiment ne
cédez pas à la tentation qu'est la
tentation si française de la pénitence
perpétuel il faut faire aimer la france
ne désignait pas la france comme un
coupable perpétuel ne faites pas comme
le président de la république en
indiquant que la france est coupable du
crime contre l'humanité le pire des
crimes
monsieur le premier ministre oui il faut
réarmer la république il faut aussi
faire aimer la france
relevons ensemble l'étendard de nos
couleurs de nos valeurs relevons
ensemble aussi l'étendard de la fierté
française l'assassinât barbare de samuel
patty a soulevé une immense colère la
france est touchée car c'est aussi
marianne qu'on a voulu décapiter
ils sont venus égorger nos fils et nos
compagnes
aujourd'hui les mots ne suffisent plus
il coule comme le sens trop souvent
versée les français exigent désormais
des actes des engagements précis des
français attendent de vous des actes
forts la mise en place d'une immigration
choisie et non pas imposé par des juges
irresponsables
l'expulsion des clandestins des
délinquants étrangers une application
sans faille des règles de la laïcité
déchéance de nationalité contre tous
ceux qui prennent les armes contre la
mère patrie la reconquête rue par rue de
toutes les zones de non droit un soutien
total à la police si si nécessaire le
renfort de l'armée
pour cela il faut un exécutif déterminer
un parlement respecter car représentant
légitime du peuple plus de renoncement
des actes s'il vous plaît votre ministre
de l'intérieur vient d'annoncer
l'expulsion prochaine de 231 étrangers
identifiés par l'administration comme
radicalisé mais ses 231 étrangers ne
représentent que 5,6 pour cent des
étrangers inscrits au fichier des
signalements pour la prévention de la
radicalisation un caractère terroriste
pourquoi pourquoi ne prenez-vous pas la
décision d'expulser tous les étrangers
est radicalisée de notre territoire
comme les députés les républicains
l'avaient proposer par voie d'amendement
en 2018 lors du projet loi asile
immigration amendements rejetés par la
majorité
pourquoi faites vous couvrir ce risque
insensée à nos concitoyens en gardant
sur notre sol des ennemis de notre pays
les islamistes se sont infiltrés dans
l'école il menace la france dans son
essence même la formation d'esprits
libres les islamistes tiennent la main
de certains parents ils envahissent
l'esprit des enfants
ils contraignent des enseignants à
modifier leurs cours pas de vagues
entendez ces hussards de la république
quand il aurait voulu crier leur
solitude ceux qui combattent la
radicalisation sont accusés d'
islamophobie
aussi est il temps de réellement
protéger les professeurs de sanctuariser
les cours d'histoire et d'instruction
civique mais aussi de science de lettres
de sport monsieur le ministre
ne doit-on pas désormais instauré un
délit d' entrave à la liberté
d'enseigner dans le cadre évidemment des
programmes définis par l'éducation
nationale
c'est un enseignant est un fonctionnaire
c'est un représentant de l'état est un
pilier de notre république en tant que
chef du gouvernement
vous vous devez de protéger tous les
fonctionnaires de france dans l'exercice
de leurs métiers dits fermés diffamé
dans l'exercice de sa fonction
menacé de mort pour avoir fait son
métier d'enseignant est victime
une véritable cabale sur les réseaux
sociaux monsieur pâtit aurait dû
automatiquement bénéficier de la
protection fonctionnelle des
fonctionnaires l'école de la république
ne doit pas reculer encore moins
indiquer les enseignants doivent être
soutenus par toute leur hiérarchie les
difficultés de ces enseignements ne se
limite pas aux établissements dans les
quartiers sensibles
la majorité des écoles sont est concerné
chacun sait la virulence contagieuse la
virulence saisonnière du virus de la
grippe
or nous ne sommes pas prêts je crains
que nous ne devions le pays de la
pénurie pénurie de médecins pénurie de
moyens dans les hôpitaux pénurie de
masques pénurie djel pénurie sur blues
pénurie de tests pénurie de lits de
réanimation pénurie d'anticipation ce
qui est encore plus grave pénurie de
vaccins la préparation est une faute
monsieur le ministre j'espère que nous
allons nous mobiliser les uns les autres
pour qu' il y ait moins de pénurie et
d'incurie dans ce pays il y a déjà
presque un an
je vous avais alertés ainsi que mes
collègues comme emilie bonnivard des
sites concernés sur la situation de
ferropem filiale du groupe ferro
atlantique à cette entreprise
hyper électro-intensives spécialisée
dans le silicium et les ferroalliages
est plus que jamais menacé alors qu'elle
est essentielle à notre pays des zones
de revitalisation rurale les lrr parmi
nos recommandations il y avait avant
tout l'idée de proroger d'un an et demi
soit jusqu'au 31 décembre de ville 2021
le dispositif actuel afin de réfléchir à
la réforme des critères et aux mesures
financières associées
en réponse nous vous nous aviez dit non
[Musique]